hi this is international master david
pruss for chess.com
with another basic checkmate that will
be of great use to you
the most common type of end games are
rook
end games and uh in many cases
when your last pawn gets close to
queening what your opponent will do is
sacrifice their rook for that pawn so
you don't get a new queen
and then you need to be able to
checkmate with a single rook
so this is also a pretty common
checkmate and of course
another point of learning these basic
checkmates is that they help you learn
how to use
these pieces in the end game in this
case you know how to use your king and
rook how to fight against an opponent's
king
this is like fundamental stuff in terms
of how to use the pieces on a very
empty board gives you a good pure sense
of how they work
so useful stuff here for anyone who
doesn't know this
as with the checkmate with a queen the
first thing you need to do is you need
to figure out what would a checkmate
look like
how could you set up these three pieces
so that it would actually be
checkmate there actually aren't a lot of
options because
this king at the very worst will have
three squares available to him plus the
square he's on four squares you have to
attack
your king and rook are not that powerful
there aren't many options for this
but this is one of them and this can
work
even if the king is a little bit in the
middle of the
side of the board and not the corner but
there's no way to checkmate him if he's
not on the side of the board right
six squares is the most you could
possibly take away from him and that
would leave him with three
outs okay
so let us realize that we need to chase
the king
to the back rank and then we need to try
and get a position where our king is in
front of him
and checkmate with the rook on the back
rank
all right so the main principle that
we're going to use
to improve our position is something
called tsuge fine and before we start
here at the beginning we're going to
start at the end so
imagine this position here
and white has just played let's say
his king in front of the opponent's king
and imagine how would you get checkmate
here so your opponent
is going to see that you're threatening
checkmate in one move and he's going to
move his king out of the way now would
this move be checkmate
no right because it would let his king
out so you need to get your king in
front of the opponent's king again right
if you want to checkmate him
but as you might well imagine his king
is not going to stand around and wait
for you to checkmate he'll step out of
the way again
so actually trying to put your king on
the square you want
vis-a-vis your opponent's king is not
getting you anywhere right he will
always just step away
so you have to use the principle of
tsuge von which is
forcing your opponent to move where you
want him to move
instead of trying to go straight for
where you want to be so
in this position for example white's
best move
is actually to play something called a
waiting move
like this with the rook the point is
your opponent's king is currently at its
best position close to the center of the
back
edge of the board but not directly in
front of your king
any move he makes will worsen his
position for example he could move here
and you would have checkmate in one move
or he could move here but now he's
closer to being stuck against the edge
of the board
now how do you follow up here now you
move your king
again if he steps in front of your king
you have checkmate
but he has to move somewhere right so he
moves towards the edge of the board
and you are continuing to worsen his
position
using the principle of tsuge fun now
tsuge fung does not come up in the
opening or middle game
very often at all it's extremely rare
but in the end game it comes up a lot
because in the end game you only have
one or two pieces there's a good chance
that they might all be on their best
square already and you don't want to
move them to worse squares
in the opening or middle game you almost
always have some pieces which
are not ideally placed and which you
could try to
improve or bring to better squares so
white is
using the fact that black has to move
against him
and black is eventually going to bump
into the edge of the board
then be forced to even step right in
front of the white king where white
wanted him
and white will checkmate the black king
now guess what if the rules of chess
didn't say that you had to move
if you had the option to pass then king
and rook
against king would be a draw because in
this position here black would just
refuse to move
he would say no i don't really need to
do anything i'm happy with where my
pieces are
you know i have nothing i need to do so
then it would be up to white to move so
white
you know would try and do this if you
wanted to checkmate the king go opposite
him
and then black would say well yeah now
i'll defend against that by moving away
and um you know then white would say
okay i put my rook over here
and now again black would say well i
don't want to step here i don't want to
move away so i'll just pass
and it would be a draw so the only
reason you can win this endgame is
because of two
following the fact that your opponent is
forced by the rules to make a move
and that is the case with a lot of
endgames that actually the way you win
is by forcing your opponent to move into
worse and worse
squares or to remove his pieces from
their best squares
and then you take over some of that
territory or
you know then you're able to affect some
kind of threat
that you had to wait for him to walk
into so from the beginning what are we
going to do well we're going to try and
gradually
restrict the black king and force him to
the back rank so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to use our
rook
to take away ranks whenever possible
okay so we'll start by
cutting the board in half right now he's
got just the top half of the board
left starts moving the king now our rook
by itself can't force the king to the
back rank
unlike the k and queen end game so we
need to bring our king in right away
anytime he attacks your brook you're
well advised to not just keep advancing
your king because you want to improve
your king position
and watch him eat your rook instead you
should show that you're slightly alert
and move your rook away but maintain it
on the file that you want
now in general what you'll find is your
rook is best placed
far away from enemy kings that way they
can't attack him but he still
controls the squares around them just as
well from a distance
so the enemy king comes here and the
white king steps up
now if the black king comes in front of
our king
we do like a mini checkmate right and we
attack like this we've covered these six
squares here
and it's not checkmate because he can
step back but that's also progress for
us right he's forced to move back
we will move our king into the center
he attacks our rook we move our rook
away
he comes here now you want to check him
when you force him back right
so what do we need here what kind of a
move
a waiting move right so we just mark
time with the rook
still maintaining the coverage of the
fifth rank
the enemy king steps away we follow
eventually he steps in front of us
we check him and he's forced back
another rank
we go after him he steps over here
we switch our rook to the other side
creating again a situation where he has
to step in front of our king or keep
moving
right so he moves we follow he steps in
front
we check he comes here we come after him
king in front of king
and if he comes this way now we've got
this knight move we don't want to chase
him right you've seen this from the
beginning we play a waiting move
excellent he steps aside we follow him
ultimately
he can't run away he bumps into the edge
of the board steps back in front of us
and checkmate and that is all there
is to checkmating with king and rook as
before
i suggest that with these kind of
fundamental positions you actually
practice playing them out
against a person or against a computer
engine you need to
successfully do this position at least
three times before moving on to other
positions
and i think doing it more than that
would be good it'll go fast once you've
learned it
so you want to restrict the king cut
them off across
ranks with the rook bring your king in
and remember this pattern of tsugsfung
right we always made progress
in a situation where our king is now a
nice move away from their king
with our rook cutting off and if he
steps
towards us we check him back and if he
steps away
from us we keep taking away his
territory with our king
and eventually he has to step in front
of us and we check him back
so good luck with that
i hope you enjoyed this video and i'll
see you around on chess.com